hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to let's play dead darkness
demo now there's not a lot of
information even on the page for this
game so I don't really know what I'm
getting myself into which is something I
say at the most of the beginning most of
these games so let's just have a new
nightmare
okay oh whoa not what I was expecting
oh okay I'm in a circular room with a
lot of doors I thought I heard like it
okay all right first impressions in this
game it's definitely got the atmosphere
right and I love this setting it just
poopy it too
it reminds me of the pocket dimension of
radical Larry and SCP containment breach
oh goodness
okay all right let's see if it can
continue this good Oh what was that I
thought I saw something it's like pitch
black I can't see anything either okay
let me back into this cuz oh no I hit a
wall oh oh okay wait a minute I can let
go off to the left here I'm slightly
concerned oh it's like pitch black I
must have hit another wall Oh Oh what
the hell where am I now where am I now
or am I now where am I now I cannot see
a thing no wonder it's called dead
darkness okay so I hit another wall oh
okay I guess I'm just stumbling around
in the dark with no idea where I'm going
oh lordy I mean uh uh haha okay can't go
that way
are you know what screw this I think I
may hit the wrong one so let's try to
get back out
maybe please could I go out now I'd
really like to go out I mean the pitch
darkness is nice and all but
really uh concerned oh wait what is this
what is this this another one am I just
gonna be wandering around here for a
while cuz I thought I don't know how i
got into here I heard that I heard that
okay yeah this game was definitely got
the atmosphere right I mean obviously
play this game in a very dark room
whatever you do as dark as possible I
only got enough lighting to liberté my
face right now
oh where am I
I can't move with that wait a minute
things are changing I'm like lost what
is with that baseline it's got to be a
way to get out of here what I'm like
okay alright maybe let me just keep
backing up because that seems to be the
way to go cuz otherwise I just get like
totally lost and oh my god I'm just
wandering in circles backing up to get a
point of reference
okay whoa what uh that's a hole in the
ground I don't want to go in a hole in
the ground
let's jump over here
keke haha little noises alright once
again still wandering around in the dark
don't know what I'm doing okay that's a
dead end
I think huh huh uh huh
I almost fell ho but I'm okay what is
with that baseline
there's someone hidden piano keys what's
going on there what's the point where am
I
I'm like this is so weird this is so
weird I don't know if this is randomly
generated or if like I I don't know I
don't know what's going on I keep
thinking if something's gonna pop up but
nothing does maybe I should have tried
to go in that hole I don't know I don't
know I don't know I don't know I don't
know I don't know I kind of feel like
I'm just wandering in circles here I'm
kind of kind of hoping that something
happens soon oh man now I'm just whoa
what uh what's that what is that what's
in the middle there what is that a teddy
bear
what that's adorable
I can't pick it up I can only push it
what's it mean what does it mean I'm
gonna push it try to push it into a hole
maybe what is this wha
Oh okay still there well look at the
little guy so adorable not really I'm
gonna lose him in the darkness again
with the base line again with the making
me carry I'm gonna lose that bear don't
know where I'm going but it's really
confusing me seriously it's like I keep
just I wander into the darkness and I
just kind of shake back and forth until
I see something and now I'm like
spinning in a 360 and I've got nothing
oh Lord I just lost my ball this game is
messing with me isn't it it is isn't it
it is I think it is I have a feeling I'm
very eager for something to happen oh
the first branching path that doesn't
have a hole in the ground all right I
don't think that there's actually like a
monster or anything in here with me
at least I hope not it's just such a
weird game um oh here we go
man it's so strange what's the point
what are you doing to me why do you keep
leaving me off into pitch blackness
Oh Oh
how do I keep popping up at different
places is so weird losing your point of
reference over and over and over again
okay all right oh wait a minute this is
the closest I've seen two of these
together no pride nothing interesting
happening wait what
it's a dead end this is it this like a
total dead end never seen a dead end
before maybe I have I don't know I would
love to have a map or something or just
some interesting have Rumble he's going
on just a rumbling bass line in the
background
gah ah damn and I'm in bad like okay
here we go
I swear I'm spinning in a 360 over and
over over again then suddenly a point of
reference will just pop up out of
nowhere I don't know what the dealio is
I don't even know what I'm looking for I
don't know what I'm looking for what am
I looking for what am I looking for
I don't think this game is intended to
be played by backing up until you hit
something uh I scare anybody oh damn and
I'm back here Jesus that's ridiculous
is there actually an exit maybe I was
supposed to fall in that hole in the
beginning maybe I was or maybe I was
supposed to push the bear into the hole
I have no idea I really don't
I'm so confused this is so weird
it's gotta be a point to it
oh no there's gotta be a point what's
the point what am I looking for
I don't know I want to get back to that
hole in the ground because I want to
throw myself into the bottom of it
that's what I want to do okay I should
have been sprinting a long time ago
because barely I can sprint forever ah
running through halls of darkness empty
like my um heart and soul empty like my
mind I don't know I don't know I don't
know I feel like I'm going the wall
okay I scared my dog oh this is a weird
there's no point that was no point to
the game I was waiting for something to
happen the whole time seriously I was
waiting for something to happen and it
got eaglet like this I should have known
something was up when there were two
lights that far off from each other that
got me good that was like one of the
best jump scares I've ever had I mean
long build-up long way to go for that
one but still oh yeah oh yeah tears you
guys huh okay all right I'm all done
here so um maybe you guys could try this
and see if there's another secret I like
I I don't think I found the ending I
don't know this is obviously only just a
demo is released very recently in
February 9th I believe so if you guys
can find a secret that I can't find go
right ahead
I've you're more than welcome to try it
but it is it like this so maybe there
was a flashlight if it was a flashlight
I'm gonna be boat so I guess gotta see
if there was a flashlight I did I never
bothered to press f so I never rather
depressed any other button besides the
WASD keys so I just need to see that'll
be done nope I'm done cuz it crashed
okay let me go let me know what you guys
think so oh yeah thank you all so much
watching click the annotation for more
video sips I've done and as always I
will see you in the next video
Wow
doctor
but